set in the year 1950 the story is about
a utopian town called Victory the small
town is surrounded by desert on all
sides several hundred residents live
here all of whom are extremely wealthy
and live a posh lifestyle all male
residents living in the town are taking
part in a mysterious project the victory
headquarters is situated at the top of a
mountain in the middle of the desert
however women are strictly forbidden to
venture into the desert Legend says that
if one ends up there they will never
return the same the women are expected
to just be concerned with their own
houses and their lives and to not
question what their husbands do for a
living they are only told that their
husbands are involved in the development
of progressive material while the
husbands spend all of their time at the
victory project headquarters the wives
get to spend their time enjoying the
beauty luxury and debauchery of their
Community the founder of this whole
place and project is Frank everyone
regards him as a hero the whole town is
regularly blasted with Frank's inspiring
speeches through speakers where he
promises to create something thing great
one day the neighborhood is organizing a
house party the attendees include our
protagonist Alice and her husband Jack
among other neighbors who all seem to be
really close to one another while the
men keep talking about how they are all
really lucky to be part of the victory
project all the women seem to indulge in
internal gossip or playing drinking
games the following morning we see Alice
cook breakfast for Jack as he gets ready
and heads out for work at the exact same
time as the other men all of them get
into their respective cars as the wives
bid them goodbye the wives then engage
in a sort of routine that includes
cleaning every Speck of dust in the
house and cooking a three-course lavish
meal for their husbands occasionally
they enjoy themselves by gathering at
the community house or by sharpening
their ballet skills under the guidance
of Shelley she is a sort of rigid woman
who seems to be hell-beds on making sure
that these women follow the rules and
regulations set by her husband and
founder of this Utopia Frank everything
seems perfect in this utopian town but
the controlled bubble of this Utopia
gets its first trigger when Frank
organizes a party to walk welcome the
newest members of the community Bill and
violet everyone is present there and
like always all the men and women seem
to be in complete awe of what Frank is
doing with Victory Town however before
he can proceed any further a woman named
Margaret steps forward she looks visibly
anxious and Disturbed but still finds
the courage to ask the question that all
of them have been dreading to ask what
are we doing here this shocks all the
attendees including Margaret's husband
as no one has ever questioned Frank
before nonetheless Frank delivers yet
another inspiring speech and Wows the
audience prompting everyone to forget
about Margaret after the speech Alice
goes looking for her husband Jack but
she unexpectedly Witnesses Margaret's
husband trying to force feed her some
pills that the town physician Dr Collins
has prescribed to her however everyone
knows that Margaret is ill so she
doesn't pay much attention and leaves
the next day as all the women Including
Alice are chatting in the community
center the topic of Margaret is again
brought up the Chatterbox of the group
bunny reveals that Margaret became
mentally ill because she failed to
follow the one rule set by Frank to not
Venture into the desert through
flashbacks we are shown that Margaret
lost her son when she was in the desert
and that trauma has set her into a
complete state of disfigurement Alice
who is listening to all of this appears
to be worried that night Alice has
nightmares where she Witnesses unusual
ballet dancers in black and white the
next day another weird thing happens as
Alice is preparing a meal she finds that
the eggs are completely empty in the
inside hence after Jack leaves for work
she takes a lorry ride to clear her mind
all the women get off at the mall but
Alice decides to continue going however
when she's about to reach the end of the
line she Witnesses a red plane losing
its balance over the desert's Skyline
panicked Alice asks the Lorry driver to
take her to the crash site but the
latter completely freezes and tells her
that he's not allowed to this is because
the plane is crashed in the middle of
the Forbidden Desert but in spite of all
the warnings Alice decides to go on her
own as she is adamant on saving the
survivors after walking for a while she
eventually reaches the desert which is
Barren and empty as expected Alice does
not find the plane or any wreckage but
what she finds is a large mountain which
leads her to a building this building is
none other than the victory Town
headquarters itself the place where all
the husbands apparently go to work
trying to get help Alice aligns her face
to the building's glass opening and the
next thing we know she is back at home
waking up from a nightmare that had
similar images to her previous
hallucination Alice is obviously shocked
and confused by the incident but she
decides to hide it from Jack
unfortunately over the course of the
next few days her waking nightmares keep
getting worse most of the time she keeps
hallucinating about the ballet dancers
and in one instance she feels like she's
being crushed by the walls of her own
house but one day everything changes she
Witnesses a depressed Margaret
committing the unthinkable Alice rushes
to save her but a bunch of men dressed
in red suddenly appear and drag her away
that night she explains the entire
incident to her husband Jack but
surprisingly he reveals that Margaret is
alive and well she never committed the
unthinkable and had just slept in the
bathroom Alice who's in complete
disbelief doesn't listen to him and
tries to look for answers but Jack calms
her down and asks her to take some rest
unfortunately for Alice her
hallucinations continue getting worse so
the town physician Dr Collins is
summoned to their house one day he
conducts some tests on her and
prescribes her some pills claiming that
she is just stressed out however Alice
asserts that she is fine and continues
asking about Margaret when she starts
becoming rude Dr Collins reveals that
Margaret is fine but her husband was
fired from his job because of her
actions and now they have been moved
from the town hearing this Alice keeps
silent for Jack's sake just then she
notices a file and Dr Collins's suitcase
that has Margaret's name on it Alice
covertly steals it while the doctor is
away and later goes through it to her
dismay most of it has been blacked out
the only thing she can find is details
about Margaret's deteriorating mental
health the next day Jack approaches her
and gives her a dress he asks her to
wear it immediately as the head of the
Town Frank has invited them to a special
event despite might not feeling 100
percent Alice obligess has she has no
other choice at the event however she
again begins hallucinating and goes into
a mental breakdown having had enough she
pleads with her husband to return home
but just then Frank calls him on stage
seemingly to make an announcement as
Alice watches on nervously Frank Praises
Jack as the ideal employee and promotes
him to the executive position the crowd
erupts in cheers and Jack starts
screaming with joy but a confused and
distraught Alice rushes to the bathroom
where she breaks down in tears on stage
Frank asks Jack to dance because Harry
Styles can't act so this is all he's
good for and like a puppet he obliges it
almost feels like it's a direct metaphor
for how all the strings in Victory town
are attached to Frank's hands and he is
just puppeteering them all through
meanwhile The Chatterbox bunny
approaches Alice in the bathroom but
instead of trying to help her she tries
to put some sense into her she tells
Alice to stop being hysterical and to
support her husband on this big night
the following day Jack organizes a
promotion party at his place and Alice
is tasked with the cooking she seems
surprisingly calm for a person who is
disoriented just the other day however
it all appears to be part of her
Mastermind plan soon all the residents
of the neighborhood arrive along with
special guest Frank and his wife Shelly
after a while as Alice is in the kitchen
Frank approaches her and says I'm sorry
bunny didn't believe you he then
commends Alice on her presence of mind
and challenges her to find out more
about the place this finally confirms
that Alice is not crazy and whatever she
is hallucinating has something to do
with this weird Town hence at dinner a
Fed Up Alice decides to take center
stage she confronts all the men about
the town's need for Perfection and
wonders why the women cannot Venture
into the desert as Jack and the others
listen in disbelief Alice draws out a
few peculiar similarities between how
all of them landed in Victory town and
how their life before it was a complete
blur strangely all the residents are
either from Baltimore or from Chicago
all of the couples met at the same train
station in the same manner and all of
them had their honeymoons in the same
venue Alice continues that all the food
products in Victory Town ranging from
vegetables to packaged food are
manufactured under the name of Frank but
despite all this no one bats an eye that
something is clearly wrong unfortunately
her claims are proven correct as all the
other diners simply think that whatever
she is saying is a hysterical Outburst
when everyone leaves Alice having
shattered Jack's reputation tells him
that there's something really wrong with
Victory town and that they should leave
immediately and despite being completely
embarrassed in front of the others Jack
agrees to whatever Alice says claiming
that he will love her no matter what
unfortunately just as they are about to
leave in their car jack starts
apologizing profusely he cannot go
through with it Alice slowly comes to
terms with his betrayal but before she
can react the same men in red from
earlier arrive at the scene and
forcefully take Alice away next we see
her receiving shock therapy the reasons
for this are not disclosed just yet but
these elector shocks are closely cut
with the actual truth of who she is we
get a rundown of Alice and her husband
Jack living in a modest apartment it is
the 21st century and not the 1950s Alice
appears to be a nurse who works late
night shifts at the hospital because
Jack has recently lost his job one night
she returns exhausted after a 30-hour
shift in which she had to oversee three
separate surgeries Jack tries to be
romantic with her but Alice is too tired
for it plus he looks greasy this shows
that the couple is slowly drifting apart
because of Alice's hectic work schedule
hence being jobless and lonely Jack
blindly starts following the preaching
videos of a personality named Frank
Frank is someone who has apparently
developed a technology that allows
couples to live in an extremely evolved
virtual reality a simulation of a 1950s
Utopia that screams Perfection from the
get-go one night Jack who has lost all
sense of control due to his fragile male
ego decides to reach out to Frank he
then learns of the victory project and
immediately decides he wants to be a
part of it not only that he forces Alice
into the experiments for a brief second
we see her Force plot plugged into the
simulation's ground control which turns
out to be their bed in the real world
soon Jack sleeps beside her and he too
enters the world of the simulation
following this we are shown a montage
that gives us more details about the
simulation we get to know that the
entire thing doesn't have Alice's
consent it is something that Jack
decides for both of them so as to gain
some kind of control over what his wife
does in the simulation Jack chooses to
have a British identity since he's very
bad at American accents and since
there's no other way to it Alice's
entire memory is wiped before she enters
Victory as a citizen we also learn later
that all the men in Victory town have
voluntarily joined in to be a member
while their Partners the women have been
held captive against their will and have
been uploaded into the simulation all
the kids that are visible in the town
are simply NPCs they are not real they
have been designed for the parents who
couldn't have children in their real
lives after the Montage ends we see
Alice completely wiped from her recent
plans to escape returning back to her
idyllic home however this time the
simulation in the lie don't seem to
carry on for too long as she gets
triggered into reality again as soon as
she recognizes the song that Jack is
humming it is one of her favorite songs
from her real life in the 21st century
which she often used to sing while at
work now everything flashes in front of
Alice and she realizes that it was her
husband who has been the culprit all
along caught red-handed Jack finally
comes clean he reveals that he did
everything for their own good as their
life in the 21st century was going
downhill Jack was jobless and Alice
didn't even have time to talk to him
properly hence he took the tough
decision and enrolled them into the
victory project where they have a
Flawless life with abundant money and
respect Jack further reveals that life
for Alice is very simple all she has to
do is make friends and relax while he
has to return back to the real world and
collect money to keep the simulation
running here it is finally revealed
where all the husbands of Victory Town
go they don't work for the development
of any Progressive material but they go
to Victory headquarters to exit the
simulation and try to earn some money in
the real world to give their lives
better lives however despite hearing all
of this Alice is still hurt that her
husband betrayed her one thing leads to
another and the two get into an argument
which ends with Alice smashing a glass
over Jack's head sadly the impact kills
him when out of the house a bloodied
Alice startles everyone and specifically
tells them that they are being
controlled by a program that Frank has
created all of the residents try to stop
her except bunny this is where we come
to learn that out of all the women only
bunny is aware of the truth behind
Victory it turns out that she agreed to
sign up for it because in the real world
her children died bunny tells Alice to
run away explaining that if someone dies
in The simulation they will also die in
the real world and now that the men in
red are coming for her Alice has very
little time hearing this a frightened
Alice immediately gets in her car and
drives off to the one place from which
she can escape the victory Town
headquarters on her way she is met by
Frank's henchman the men in red have
been tasked to capture Alice or possibly
to kill her consequently stopping her
real-life body from ever waking up this
step is taken because Alice never signed
up for the project and if she wakes up
and reports to the authorities about it
Frank's Empire will be doomed somehow
she evades the Thugs and reaches the
mountain however Midway her car breaks
down so she is forced to flee on foot
while the men in red follow her closely
elsewhere as Frank is following the
entire development via call his wife
Shelley surprisingly stabs him in the
chest and kills him before she departs
she simply says it's my turn now [ __ ]
meanwhile Alice reaches the top of the
mountain but just when she is about to
approach the window of the headquarters
she has one of her Visions where she
sees Jack asking her to stay in Victory
and be with him however free from
control and having developed a conscious
of her own Alice ignores him and
eventually touches the glass of the
headquarters window for a second the
screen Fades to Black and before the
film ends we briefly hear a woman
gasping for air signifying that Alice
has teleported back to the real world
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching